In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 9, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Joseph of Volokolamsk, Saint Joseph was born of a noble family in the province of Kaluga.
At the age of 20, he left the world and entered the most austere monastery of the region.
His father, his mother and his brother, who afterwards became bishop of Rostov, all followed
his example and embraced the angelic life.
After receiving the monastic habit, the young Joseph worked in the infirmary where he
took care of his sick father for fifteen years.
Shortly before his death, St. Pavnutios, abbot of the monastery of Borovsk, designated Joseph
as his successor.
When he took office, he wanted to introduce a stricter teapicon, rule of senobitic life.
But the brethren of the monastery were against it.
This led Joseph to make a long journey around all the monasteries of Russia in order to study
their teapica, and, of them all, he preferred that of the monastery of St. Cyril of white lake.
In the end, he did not go back to Borovsk, but made his way to Volokolamsk in his native
province.
There, in the midst of the forest, he founded a monastery dedicated to the dormitian of
the Mother of God, where he was able to order monastic life according to the strict form
he sought.
It was this very austerity that attracted large numbers of disciples who wanted to follow
Christ by taking their cross and dying to themselves daily through holy obedience.
Joseph welcomed rich and poor in the same fatherly way, appointing exactly the same rule
of life for nobles who placed themselves under his direction, as for their servants who
followed them.
The ascetic observance was the same for all.
All were clothed in the same coarse material, and all undertook the same round of work.
In this life of complete renunciation, the saint made exception for the weak and the aged,
teaching the brethren to leave their own obedience when they needed help, as God's commandment
of love is to be preferred to every commandment of men.
At the time, the Russian state was reviving after casting off the totter yoke, but the whole
land was impoverished and life was very hard.
And Joseph relieved all who were distressed and taught the rich and powerful to show mercy
toward their subjects.
During a whole year of Grievous famine, he gave food and shelter in his monastery to
around 1,000 children.
About that time, the young prince John of Volokalamsk died without the sacraments, and was restored
to life by the prayer of Saint Joseph, who confessed him and gave him to partake of
the holy mysteries, whereupon the young man went to his eternal rest.
Through his inspired teaching and the example his monastery offered of a correct understanding
of Christian ascetic practice, Saint Joseph stood out against the heresy of the judaizers
that afflicted Novgorod at the time, together with Janaviyos, Bishop of Novgorod, Joseph secured
their condemnation at the councils that met in the years 1490 and 1504.
Monasteries were being established throughout the Russian land, and an increasing number of
rich people were giving them property and other material goods for the sake of their spiritual
assistance in prayer before God.
So the question arose whether the possession of land and worldly goods by monasteries was
agreeable to the poverty required of them by the gospel.
Saint Joseph contributed to the debate by defending the right of monasteries to great possessions,
but with the sole aim of serving the church and the poor.
In this case, wealth is no longer selfish gain, but the common good of the whole church
to hasten the day of the coming of God's kingdom upon earth.
This view which was approved by the councils of 1503 and 1504 is, in fact, compatible with
the position taken by St. Nilos of Soda that monks should live in renunciation and poverty.
Both currents of thought have their place in the church, and in practice often exist side-by-side.
Saint Joseph fell asleep in the Lord on the 9th of September in the year 1515 and was
buried in the church of his monastery.
His memory was added to the calendar in the year 1591.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.